now i've known you for a long time i met
you back in like 1988 or something we
were watching
88 we're both on that show upstairs yeah
that's right started out live
yeah yeah and uh you know i remembered i
used to i used to talk to you a lot i
i thought you were a very funny guy very
smart guy you had a lot of insights
about women
you you taught me a lot right cause i
couldn't get any
that was horrible then someone said
money
really yes just give them cash
give them cash it always works really
yeah it's just what they want really
yeah yeah huh uh what
i don't know you know what i'm noticing
about women lately they love compliments
so much
you have to give them compliments all
the time even for things that aren't
obvious like
a woman could cook you up a plate of
food you could eat everything
on the plate including the fork if you
don't say the food was good
in five minutes she may start crying
right now
how am i supposed to know if it's any
good i ate the fork
want me to bite the plate come on
you know what about your except if it's
a white woman
oh really yeah then you you just go you
see it
[Laughter]
then you gotta eat nothing man you know
how to cook for no brother just throw it
away
i say that all the time to my woman
yeah it doesn't work no no never let a
white woman cook for you
really i know if i can just lead you
down this road you'll get in trouble you
know it's real funny i don't even know
where i'm going yeah
i just throw it out there you uh your
summer going okay everything all right
sometimes it's great it's just hot man
you know giuliani's cracking down on
coal
so
no coal man
he doesn't like that and topless cold
here
giuliani can't stand it yeah how come
you're not sweating
what's wrong with this guy someone told
me you had a running with the police
this time dude
you know every day i have to carry my
nine conan every day
[Laughter]
it's hard i keep my nine by my side
coded every day
i had to check it before i got it here
but you know sometimes you have to do
that for white it
all right uh you're telling me i'm
telling you i had a cop pulled me off
the other day
scared me so bad made me think i stole
my own car
get out the car you stole this gun life
hey maybe i did
he talked you into it right into it wow
i'm on probation right now
got to clean out toilets and stuff yeah
big problem big problem man now um
everything's i mean things are going so
great for you you changed it all i mean
you know i know you in the old days have
you just gone to your head at all it has
all gone to my head
good oh conan remember when i used to
come here how i used to sit down for the
whole show
yeah i ain't even here right now
you were there four minutes ago
[Laughter]
i came back in to see you before the
show you made me dance for you yeah
man and i did it i'm like i got the
entourage going man you know bodyguards
can i have one person from your
entourage yes i don't have an on me and
andy need an entourage just one guy
you really really do boy why'd you go
that way man
i got no joke for that
why'd you go there maybe i didn't want
you to get a laugh
whoa oh wow
perfect my trap works
i had it with whitey putting me down
yeah
oh my god let me plug your special
bigger and blacker
bigger and blacker so black you won't
even see me
[Applause]
i've heard that where is he adjusted a
special filter
that is saturday night at 11 15 on hbo
and the bigger and blacker cd which we
were listening to today
really funny is available yes and uh
that's
real big and really black
nicely done yeah chris congratulations
on everything
thank you chris rock everybody jennifer
esposito coming up we'll take a break